the most popular animator in the
entirety of the industry kind of
selectively chooses which anime he does
good work on this one has really gotten
under my skin the scene being picked at
here isn't actually nakamura's key
animation this is from the recent Eureka
7 movie where he served as an animation
director and it's someone else's work
he's redrawing here to bring it up to a
better standard when you're correcting
work across an entire movie yeah of
course you're not going to go all out in
other people's stuff besides you take
one look at his own stuff for the Eureka
7 TV series and you see he sure does
care but here's the thing you may still
look at this and think well that doesn't
look like his best work and you wouldn't
be wrong but you also have to understand
that different Productions have
different schedules and production
Scopes and animators can only work
within the time and resources they're
given I assure you that that does not
make them lazy